citizens of the reject Nation we are
here once more for some Brooklyn
Nine-Nine double feature episodes 5x17
and 18 as we move our way through the
season Greg how are you feeling you
would have had a very long day so I'm
excited to just relax with this amazing
comedy cherry on top thanks to prepper
for cutting down the highlights and if
you want to join us for the full length
thing come over to patreon.com the real
rejects you know what to do let's watch
the show
so do you recognize any of these men I
was hiding in the bathroom stall so I
didn't see his face but I heard him he
was singing along to the music at the
bar do you remember what he was singing
I think it was that song I want it that
way
yes yes you are oh goodness one could
you please sing the opening to I Want It
That Way really you are
going the one
number three
they're all good
it's conducting
[Laughter]
yes
you and me both Jake
ah chills literally it was number five
number five killed my brother oh my God
I forgot about that part
[Music]
whoever whoever came up with that goated
for life
I can't believe it's finally gonna
happen
yeah do sex 24 saves 369 no no
aggressively overcomated now it seems
like we have problems Big Sisters flying
in from Dallas and we're picking her up
at the airport and they're gonna 369
with her ATL and EWR didn't respond when
I reached out but DFW is DTM down to
meet well did you get going her flight's
gonna land soon but wish me luck I'm
about to be your brother SNL star SNL
star good acronyms my squash Club
recently transitioned to racquetball
since I'm not a dope smoking hooligan I
decided to quit boy let's teach me yo
Genevieve got me into it you can't
believe how many different ways I can
wrap my legs around her six
health is about flexibility and peace of
mind and Bone strength I use all of
these really even the large neck ones
they help me sleep up right on airplanes
just because you don't have the bone
strength of a yogi we all have our thing
you're a musler I'm a boner nice yep
nice nice nice Ralph it's a yoga Beast
watch give me a yoga to do uh well we're
in warrior pose now but I suppose for
you we can start in child's pose Harry
is not a child
[Laughter]
and oh boy that is all good are you okay
Jeffords I'm fine oh man you gotta
stretch more buddy I'm going to walk out
of here normally using my trademark Tiny
Steps okay
oh no tiny Terry still have a
chiropractor man it's tiny little bites
of people when he hugs them goodbye I
tipped off page six I don't know why
they're sitting on it just looking on a
dating app weird lame gross dumb freak I
never gotta meet your girlfriend what
who they were seeing who's
gonna tell us we just started calling
her Becky
broke up sheets too much like every day
it happened twice okay we'll listen
we're in luck what was the soup you know
what men aren't difficult because
they're all secretly monsters but now
that I know you're bi that changes
everything I know so many great women
the only thing I'm not good at is
Modesty because I'm great at it
it's my kind of joke what's wrong how do
you look like that I'm so nervous my
hands are shaking and my butt is hella
sweaty I totally understand these weak
arms are heavy what if this is a uncut
situation oh no that pen pal service is
shut down you just have to relax and be
yourself what if I'm the monkey Jake
right you're right it's gonna be great
it's the biggest fear see each other
from across the room we'll lock eyes
I'll say noise she'll say toy
she's a prisoner
is that Jenny slate
I was gonna say Jenny Slade earlier damn
it
are we doing table apps or solo apps uh
table apps and lots of them if it is
fried it must be tried Johnny Cochran
right
so what I actually meant was I don't
know we should probably think it's nazim
pedrod I'm not sure
at the same time so I went to the
bathroom and started vaping to calm down
and this weird ass lady comes up to me
and I'm like you're trying to tell
me your kid doesn't like the smell of
cotton candy right
they're the worst yeah Amy because
they're the worst also I slapped a
stewardess real hard
with my fist oh no oh my God are you mad
at me oh no I messed this up I am so
sorry Jake I think I'm just gonna leave
no don't leave okay it's fine I get it
it's so crazy that we're finally meeting
each other so just forget about the
plane that's ancient history what an
awkward situation to be in it was about
us getting to know each other so let's
do that what's your favorite scene in
Die Hard Die what oh no no no no no no
you're not related when was the last
time you saw your dad I mean I've only
ever met him like nine times this will
count the time he sent his co-pilot
Steve to hang out with me because he was
too hungover I remember there's Steve he
taught me how to shave he taught me how
to shave where Steve was the where
[Music]
smart way to draw the parallels of
sometimes they're getting along
similarity sometimes they're not totally
fine here I can prove it
Terry looks constipated Terry you can't
have felt that went well for you it's
okay Sarge just admit you can't handle
yoga I can handle it fine it's a little
sore for my real workouts with weights
now man I've got work to do oh boy drop
my phone you know what
our contract is up it's time for an
upgrade anyway
[Music]
he's really selling this where's your
secret Napper I don't know what you're
talking about
space heater we sound proof for maximum
privacy and there's sodas and candy in
the mini fridge wow that looks very
relaxing big nap room and you gave it to
Gina to pump breast milk in remember
right what about this place I will burn
your life to the ground
and there's a spray if you fart
okay
one parent teacher conference my dad
went to he had sex with my teacher on
top of the diorama I made of the first
thing he's given dad
good enough about our dad what's going
on in your life I lost my job and the
love of my life Kurt just broke up with
me Amy has seven brothers maybe you
could date one of them or Rosa which one
has the best body Tony right it's very
clearly Tony I don't know why she
hesitated Tony got bad Tony it is anyway
that's my boring
walk across the Brooklyn Bridge to the
time squirrel of garden and get her
pictures taken with a human statue right
real New York yeah are you sure wow that
is so sweet and totally unnecessary what
are you doing life hack hey there's
glass in my food oh my God oh my God
what kind of restaurant is this yeah
glass
it's probably from the airline alcohol
bottles watch this milk milk lemonade
around the corner fudge is amazing that
is amazing isn't that what do you want
to find your love oh come on check it
out Danica 34 the only female noise toit
okay we'll take a Gandara Jessica nice
toit and a truly you know who doesn't
surf Gabrielle I'm out come on
disgusting Oh shot if I mess it up fine
I'll drop it and I'll never bring it up
again fine one day enjoy have it sexual
fun with lynettes lesbian friend okay
I want one she's a con woman look she's
a Survivor she's had a really hard life
I thought I had a bad because I would
only see my dad for like an afternoon
once a year but compared to her I was a
real DJ Tanner Full House her dad was
always around yeah I've seen Full House
I have good I haven't seen
not that I would ever remember sounds
like you're breaking stuff hey I'm sorry
were we being too loud I'm William I
thought you just wanted a picture oh we
took a lot of pictures get in here oh no
he's my brother it doesn't bother me
okay
[Music]
Terry can't move couch lock Jerry needs
help
[Music]
he needs to pain his butt he wears pants
look I'm sorry about all this I really
thought dedicated so I would leave
Dallas and move to New York to be near
you great but you know it's so expensive
here I'll be fine I got a head full of
dreams and a pocket full of glass I'm a
New Yorker now forget about
the only reason Kate wants to move here
is because Kurt dumped her but what if
we could get him to take her back what
if he's a rational person and he doesn't
want to be with her anymore he just
posted a black and white photo of a dead
flower with the hashtags my heart Cape
forever and love is dead he misses her
for some reason
let's get back together all we have to
do is convince him to fly here Jake this
might work yes but are we actually gonna
do this Are We Really Gonna Fly a man
who's current gonna be he could be in
grave danger and you just flippantly
called him Sergeant God I'm the worst
who does that it's probably fine what
then why did you make me feel so bad to
teach you a lesson about the destructive
power of wordplay
[Music]
oh Terry
you can definitely hear it I know you
just got to be listening for it so
excited you're moving here we thought
why not go straight home and celebrate
it exactly eight o'clock correct Kurt
the Kurt oh my God what are the chances
oh what if Kurt's a horrible guy
breaking up with you was the biggest
mistake of my life it was and he flew
all the way to New York to tell me that
that's
heat what's that now I think I'm gonna
let my skank parole officer stand in the
way of true love
hurt hey well that that worked nope it's
gonna backfire it's too soon actually I
think I know where he is I could take
you there but you need to wear
blindfolds no okay I guess you'll just
die in Supply Closet up then he's in
Supply Closet F great work I mean I
guess that's good I don't know I just
don't love you buddy
are you okay Charles was right I
couldn't handle yoga well we're here now
I'll get a couple of officers to help
lift you up no need I can handle this oh
he's gonna hurt himself you're about to
enter the bone Zone another thing oh
yeah
Guardians of the Galaxy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what are you drinking I'll have a
margarita but like a skinny Margarita so
like tequila and lime and a tiny splash
of agave I refuse to order that I heard
her what do you want Oh that's gonna be
the love oh Kurt and I talked and I'm
sorry Jake I know I said I'd stay in New
York but well sounds like the universe
just really wants you to be in Dallas
but and so did the kids oh you have kids
Kurt has six who's watching them now the
state
that's William he is a human statue I
know cheat on me we were broken up and
you cheated on me like 10 times
10 times we were dating because you were
sad all the time because my mom died oh
no in March so recent
you're not good enough for my sister I
didn't realize you were This Tall Kurt
the hell man you're the one who flew me
out here and begged me to bring her back
to Dallas okay yo this is just
escalating
begged him to get rid of me hey I found
my wallet thanks guys
true
there goes in America so he was a robot
man
until that is I'm on the voice at which
point you'll see me
[Music]
she's gonna do bad on The Voice she's
very pretty though but why are you
coming into work so late it's almost
like you spent the night somewhere I
don't know like maybe the bartenders she
knew it you're a great Matchmaker thank
you and you know what I'm just glad that
you found the courage to tell me how
great I am have a fun night this is not
on us I mean it was crazy of her to
think moving to New York was a good idea
right take responsibility Jake your
sister is a lot to take you shouldn't
feel bad that you don't want her around
constantly right I say whatever gets rid
of her
meticulous listen the choice is yours
lawsuit or upgrade me to business class
this woman said she cut her hand on a
ticketing kiosk but somebody saw her
pull out a bag of clothes my healing
glass
about it what kind of airport is this
I was trying to get rid of you because
you're a little bit of a mess kind of
like Dad oh I'm definitely a mess but I
was being like Dad too I was trying to
have a relationship with you completely
on my own terms thank you for saying
that Jake especially your hot family
members the hottest family member yes
they accept your invitation to move in
with you she's joking she's joking pick
up on it but maybe we can keep in touch
I would really like that man I was
worried you were never going to want to
see me again are you kidding well you
stood up for me with Kurt you're a great
big brother Mr name nazim pedrod okay
yeah real busy anyway
planes leaving come here
voice
all right sis have a safe flight no
vaping no promises she is bad at singing
could be worse man
could be worse
all right people get ready to sync up
Jenny slate is the one who's in
everything everywhere all at once with
the dog
that's the SNL member that is anyway
episode 18 get ready to sync up one two
three it's a huge emergency I have to
deal with first oh no is everything okay
it's about my food truck I have to get a
parking spot oh that doesn't sound as
intense as you were making it out to be
it's the best fighting and everyone
wants it get the hell out of the way I
don't know Granny Charles I
leave
the entire food truck industry is racing
to get into this one spot ah you have no
idea
we're on the Fury Road
foodie Road
[Applause]
whoa
oh they made it
interesting button on that they're
embracing fantasy slightly more overtly
these couple episodes
I mean it's comedy sitcoms what happens
you go more heightened I was wrongfully
imprisoned last year that was fun every
aspect of owning a food truck is fun
this is fun fun
and the cops would you go back to your
garbage truck and cook some pudding
you're gonna regret this kill yourself
true wow your truck is kind of stressing
me out
that was like the real end of that cold
open anyway I don't see how this is bad
news because the commissioner raised
like all of life is a popularity contest
Gina you need to run his social media
account if the mayor wants to make me
the next NYPD commissioner it'll be
because of my record and my
qualifications it's not my social media
presence okay that is not the world we
live in sir just have to find a way to
reduce expenses I've started saving 200
a month just by buying John Wick instead
of renting it every two nights
[Laughter]
okay look I hate to ask this but if you
consider shutting the truck down you're
always bragging about how much oil is
left to give up I took out a loan for
the truck I got Amy to invest it's all
gonna work out you're right you know if
I just work hard and stay positive sure
it'll be a huge success and everything
will be okay it's not life it's all I
can never find happiness
someone robbed a bodega on 4th Street
fifth one this week it's so sad that
someone's targeting bodegas they're part
of the fabric of New York shop at them a
lot no they overcharge for everything
and they sell rat poison right next to
the bananas this is the first time we're
seeing her here yeah and her like full
Sergeant get up you're hiding something
nice because I said nerd thing yes oh
you're looking at wedding dresses that
one's dope it's not what I was doing
it's broken Y2K I'll fix it
there it's fixed
it's okay you're a weird Sergeant so
maybe you'll get some money for this and
you can pay off your debts starting with
Amy you can pay off your debts starting
with Amy whoops I did it again it's a
miracle oh my God I did it again oil no
way
I ended up in a fight with a bear and I
had to think to myself headbutt him in
the penis push him over a cliff I bet
that works with a lot of animals only
the male ones learn that the hard way
easier ways than burning down your truck
right it's obviously arson you did it
you're not going to get a dime and I'm
probably going to go to jail what's
going on with you guys give me that
juicy 99 gossip
yeah oh I missed him so much Charles
loved this truck it's this baby there's
no way he'd burn it down the world is a
messed up Place Jake people
kill their parents it's the service
truck been doing pretty terrible I was
just saying it's a miracle burned down
okay I know Charles sounds hella guilty
right now but you know he didn't do it
anybody else that might have done this
any enemies oh my dad's best friend and
I have a pretty intense rivalry but I
don't think my aunt would do anything
illegal one guy you argued with rice
pudding truck guy oh my God the Pastor
Troy we just got into a fight about this
very parking spot he said I'd regret it
yeah and that's what happened you're
regretting it come on you know he didn't
commit our sin Adrian This Is Us not the
TV show this is us look me in the eyes
look me in the eyes like the bear did
oh
[Laughter]
I believe you and together we're gonna
catch the SOB that did this I'm so glad
he didn't head about me in the penis
that's how I was thinking
I'll give it time I won't be resorting
to foolish gimmicks involving my dog how
cute would cheddar look in this hat
please when it comes to clothes cheddar
wears little booties in the snow or
cheddar wears nothing yeah oh natural I
have some hard questions for that rice
pudding bastard so Adrian I think uh
Hall's gonna need to make the social
media account his own got engaged what
the hell how come I didn't know I
thought we were supposed to be friends
it was at Halloween
Charles are you just finding out about
this too no I was there who else got to
be a part of this nobody you know just
Terry and Rosa okay and Hitchcock and
Scully seriously and this creepy guy
named Bill oh bill you just left town
and we don't exactly have a text
relationship I texted you I'm at the
Gaga concert you here question mark
question mark I just didn't hear about
this one thing I mean I can't imagine
there were any other major Milestones
that I've missed are there I mean Amy's
a sergeant no it holds up for
commissioner seriously and Dr Ronald Yee
came to the precinct and taught a course
on forensics
you haven't thought about
Rosa did you dump her
I'm storming out I'm storming that I
thought about you hourly pass at the
bodegas south of fourth and I'll
coordinate with the um hourly pass by of
the wait what was that that was me
talking about hourly fast buys oh yeah I
heard about the hourly pass by that
subtle side look
a bra is a bright outfit why are you
being such a nut job about looking for a
wedding dress being a female sergeant is
difficult I have to work twice as hard
to gain my officers respect and looking
at girly dresses isn't going to help get
married in your uniform there are no
cops around nobody's going to see you
try one on okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay hell yeah
they are closed we will come back later
Adrian girl he seemed upset should we be
worried always we should always be
worried about it excuse me Troy lineker
we I know exactly who you are you spot
still a son of a
detective Boyle's truck burned down yeah
you get it you torch my truck and you're
going to jail oh I'm sorry man but I
would never do anything like that I
swear it wasn't me well I'd love to
believe you Troy oh my God he had so
much proof he named every member of the
monkeys he even got torque no one gets
torque I know all right so if it wasn't
Troy the question is who could have been
what's up jerk oh you did it if you can
hide your engagement from me what else
are you capable of hiding come on don't
you think that's a bit of a stretch look
what I found in Boyle's wife's closet
looks to me a lot like Germantown oh I
would oh yeah
story
if that's the case no oh I thought
you're reaching for a gun oh no my
friend this is much worse than a gun
this is a stamp a stamp that says
denied oh your claim is denied
stamp got much stronger in the cut
I understand you have a problem with Mr
pimento yes we sort of have a
complicated pre-existing relationship
which I think is a conflict of interest
okay I'll be honest we've had some
problems with Mr pimento before I think
he may have broken into my apartment
once oh no filing a complaint about you
you're obviously listening I don't know
I'm trying to lie oh we're locked in
great first you try and get me fired my
therapist you're a couple of dinguses
dinguses helping me work on my rotator
cuff oh I see it's a physical therapist
oh he's very physical Charles
see that
tabs I file hard I need strong tabs I'll
spin
all units attempt at 10 30 Charlie
bodegaon Smith heading East on Baltic
it's us we're on Baltic oh crap that was
him bridesmaid Style
hey someone just catch this on social
media yeah you have a weapon
I have already set up my accounts and
not to toot my own bugle but I think I
did an admirable job
526-1796 d6e6
420-486 F6 c74 it spells Raymond Holt in
hexadecimal code
[Music]
tasty lemon drop Olivia Crawford oh look
at that an alert I'm probably trending
already what my account has been
deactivated Twitter thinks you're a bot
why I'm a human male
yes
beautiful delivery favorite shape oval
of course favorite scent trick question
you lost your sense of smell in a
shipwreck
love you guys
sorry about how things went down it's
just as much my fault as yours I could
have kept in touch with you guys and
probably should have told you about my
new family your new what now
uh gentlemen are innocent and are free
to go you're fired Adrian what and as
for you my supervisor and I reviewed
your case turpentine is all the proof we
need to deny your claim
it wasn't me Oh no you're so lame you
know that Travis wait a second is this
just because I did Molly with your
daughter you did we got no leads I'm not
gonna get any of the money back what do
we do we go directly to Travis's house
right now and burn that place to the
ground didn't you just tell me you fired
someone yeah Ted I took him out to
dinner he thought I was getting a
promotion the whole thing he wept a lot
not as much as he hired somebody
he never gave you my key back he said he
lost his hunch but we should go to his
house and burn it down and then Burn It
To The Ground no no burning of anything
I'll hold that close to your beard
amateur move you should never copy paste
if you're a perv it's quite the Scandal
so I guess this proves I was right all
along and why is Cheddar wearing a beret
uh
we started an Instagram account for
cheddar who now has over 14 000
followers well it's an incredible
feeling
how come you have all this turpentine
and this plastic bag filled with matches
and magnesium found a buried under the
back porch and I'm no expert but it
seems like that's the kind of stuff
you'd use to light a fire right oh there
you go where are you gonna set him on
fire yeah
you've been did not butt slammed wait
what denied like the stamp ah that is so
much better but slammed is so stupid is
that the wedding dress from the Erica
Summerfield 2018 fall collection no way
the bodice is totally different why do
you two know so much about wedding
dresses the only thing you can look at
around here with safe search on
while wearing a wedding dress you leapt
over a couch sprinted down an alley and
jumped off a car to do the crap out of a
purple like you were Wonder Woman was
pretty cool isn't it Amy you are an
amazing cop and a great leader hot there
you go and I would like it to have some
lace and a sweetheart neckline thank you
very much what else and I want a mermaid
cut with two lip sleeves say it again
say it loud a mermaid cut with tulip
freaking sleet I'm out of the food truck
business and I no longer start
spontaneously weeping I got myself fired
right plus it doesn't matter we got a
way better job now I'm working at one of
those fancy hand lotion stores spoiler
alert I have a gun again oh God
but it smells great I love it I can get
you some well listen man I've got
something for you really for me an
invitation did you run that by Rosa I
can't make this this is the same night
as Lady Gaga oh thank God I didn't run
it by Amy so this worked out great for
both of us but honestly nobody's gonna
come to this because everybody's gonna
be a Gaga
yeah
ah what a delightful Duo of episodes
it's hard not to immediately just get
sucked into the joy and excitement of
seeing Adrian pimento again I think
while I enjoyed the first episode the
second one really did uh kind of have
that extra amount of oomph just because
I mean we got a couple of really nice
guest stars but uh I don't know there's
just something about Jason mansoukas
that is just a force when he is on
screen and especially when he's
collaborating with this crew he's just
such a great wild presence
so uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
uh but before I just steal the whole
experience away what did you think of
this this this Brooklyn's it's good man
it's good it's all right
I left
I thought yeah
I thought that was funny as some jokes
um
good cold open
was really funny yeah
[Music]
beard is bushier than ever actually saw
my sister yeah that's right yeah setting
in lives nothing petrod yeah
you were right you said it would be a
guest star you were right okay
I mean I think that the episode itself
was
on the system is really good yeah the
I think it was a good episode
gave a nice you know moral of a story
maybe not like the most left funny but
it definitely had sort of uh
you know real heartfelt quality about it
foreign
reminded me of my own family no but we
should get serious all right let's do it
okay okay
take two take two
I had a great time oh yeah with it
where'd you go
I'm right here oh like the opening scene
okay in particular yeah yeah yeah of the
Backstreet Boys song I love what you're
saying right now I can't really hear
myself oh that's okay so can you hear me
it's okay the opening scene yeah
whoa whoa you don't have to yell right
here
but maybe just for the folks at home you
could yell a little bit
cold open
was uh the cold open was um I say this I
want to say one of the best cold ovens
I've ever seen
and then I immediately follow that up
with can I follow that up with another
cold open I really remember is it the
best
I can't think of another cold opener so
I know there's a great one and I can't
either yeah that that was a really funny
one though because I thought it was
worked on so many levels of
all of them are good singers and then
how it turned into like an acapella
session orchestral one and Jake losing
sight of the real Mission at hand again
so caught up in that with the it's like
a good little skit like that's a perfect
sketch that right there you don't even
need to like know the show or the
characters at all that could literally
just be this one clip that you put
online yeah yeah and it's a perfect
little sketch uh so yeah I thought that
was really that was really funny uh the
sister storyline I've I've thought like
the cold open was hilarious but the
actual episode itself was
um it was okay I like the emotion behind
it with them you know the show deals a
lot with parental stuff I wonder what
that writer's room is like this show
deals a lot with them the character
these characters constantly trying not
to be like their parents and that must
be an awkward situation to run into with
your estranged sibling yeah and you know
Jake has his qualities that are in their
own ways as well uh yet they they don't
ever showcase any of those sides in
front of the sister but that was still
still fun and reasonably Charmed no
there's some really funny stuff there I
like the stuff with Kurt and like the
little reveals he would have and they're
like little lines here there the B story
with Terry was
find him injuring himself that that's
just that little
um siphoned off room they have there
that does look appealing though I would
love that I'd love to have that room the
insulation yeah that that storyline made
way for a couple really good like Scully
bits and then the It ultimately I think
was just building to the whole boil just
is that bone strong yeah you know which
these two do feel like markedly at least
in like fleeting little moments more
height and more Fantastical at times but
that storyline yeah I was sitting there
thinking through that episode I was like
I'm amused I'm happy I'm spending time
but this isn't like an uproariously
funny episode where they're like just
jokes flying right right uh I I wonder
if she should probably come back the
show does a good job of bringing stuff
back actually things that you don't
think we get brought back will get
brought back at least once a season So
eventually this will get brought back
and the other storyline had something to
do with the truck right yeah uh
there's a fun that was a fun opening gag
to Punk hold open as well and I'm sorry
to see that that storyline got canned
because I thought it was something
special for Boyle yeah I did too it's
it's so in line with his character from
so early on in the show and it's also at
a point where they are putting in more
and more serial details from the season
thus far in ways that you know you'll
not be like super lost if you don't
remember quite but that do feel like oh
no like you're actually building these
into the plot lines and into the
characters right and so yeah I'm kind of
equally
unless they're gonna make way you know
kind of like they we were like so bummed
out when Rosa broke up with pimento but
then that opens up an interesting
storyline for her and and that at least
opens us up again to having the surprise
pimento sure so yeah so maybe like
they'll have some a new kind of Journey
for Boyle in The Culinary space to go on
at some point just because it seems like
out of all of his quirks one of the few
that should be sort of front and center
in a way yeah he's such a foodie that's
very true that's very good point
um and the storyline uh oh it's doing so
oh
pimento returning
is just a it's just a gem to me there's
a character that should just maybe some
people do find him annoying because this
character's supposed to be off-putting
uh but he he just wins my heart over man
he is his Basket Case of eccentricity
that I have I've always loved and that
there's a reason he's the most number
one reoccurring guest star because he's
just that good of a performer well yeah
and he he's just he has this magic he
has this really beautiful balance of
like yeah unhinged like you said kind of
off-putting but always in in a way that
still Whimsical and still lovable even
if it is like a little dissonant or a
little crazed like I don't know at least
for me pimento is yet to cross the line
into like okay now that's just too much
or now that's off-putting for real well
they don't dress him to look like a like
a hobo or something they I think the key
to it is you keep him really scruffy you
you keep his like a beard unkempt
however you you keep as close codes you
know looking sharp and Polished yeah
that way he can still have an appeal
yeah I think that is the secret to him
if it's like It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia they probably have him look
like really crusty yeah yeah like
probably just lean into that yeah but
you know they he gets these jobs that
require him to dress nicer and I think
that is the ingredient to still make him
some to not be like
just gross you can always see how he
would have gotten the job at first yeah
and you can always see how he won't have
the job for long yeah it's like his
insecurities I don't really know Jason
man I've totally lost sight of what
Jason manzukas's other work was really
like or what his personality is on
whether it be podcasters stand-up comedy
I I I really completely lost sight of
that uh so it got me curious to see it
because he just slips into this role
like seamlessly yeah it's really it's
like effortless the way he does it well
it feels so much like someone was like
I've got a great character for this guy
in particular yeah and he feels so much
yeah it's like this is my main
association with him I know I've seen
him in other stuff but since then it's
you know this is easily the most
consistent Association I have and so now
it's like if I see him in anything else
I feel like he does have some of this
flavor just as part of his sort of
natural array of character that he
brings to any project but you know
there's also the Nuance here of what
pimento pimento so yeah and it's
physical gags too are really funny too
like when he was drinking the gas or
what was it called turpentine yeah that
was really that's like the timing on the
on the physical gags as well are so well
done and they always make for really
good
not like cutaways or like editing based
jokes where it's about like yeah the
quick cut or the quick reaction in time
with some kind of cut or the zoom yeah
totally
alrighty
um yeah that was really fun man good ass
episode really fun and then how many oh
and they got the bridesmaids dresses and
all that stuff yeah that was weird
um odd one but I I understand the
reasoning behind Amy not wanting to
research this at work but I'm like it
also seems out of her characters are not
want to find her wedding dress I know it
seems like she would be absolutely all
about that just off the clock or
something but it was cool to at least
watch her like do that action scene that
seemed like she was doing some of those
stunts I mean yeah it seemed like she
was throwing down on that which is cool
alrighty well guys what did you think
about this episode John what am I doing
oh guys what did you think about this
episode so you comment like Greg now but
then do a separate comment and let me
know step all over your toes I'm sorry
hey man we discussed this all right get
it together man get it together you're
making me look like an idiot in front of
the reject I'm sorry Nation leave a like
on the video and we'll see you for more
Brooklyn nine nine but should we do a
shout out first if she won I guess let's
do a show
Adelia Chamberlain do this great man
there's anybody who I wish would just
like pop into our lives just at random
once a year with crazy energy it would
be you do assistant and if anybody was
capable of helping me choose a wedding
dress I'm pretty sure it would be you
that's what I'd like to think also not
only those things that we both like to
think of ourselves if there was anyone I
was gonna start a food truck with Adelia
be you absolutely you would be so good
at keeping all these things together and
up and running and you know what else
you would be good at is coming up with
like a really Posh break room I think
you'd be good at that as well and on top
of that you can run my social media from
now on I think I would do much better
than I do at that particular aspect of
life you know take as many creative dog
pics as you want and uh if anyone was
gonna you know commit an act of arson
against me
I would be least distressed to find that
it was you yeah because if you did it
you probably had a good reason so I
appreciate you Delia and uh Susie's
doing how's Susie doing Adelia
yo Susie go on
no idea Adelia is talking right now you
know Susie I know Susie
do you know Susie yeah
who's Susie Joe
is this a test
I'm not falling for it
you know who Susie is
her dog
how is Susie
is she doing all right
what kind of dog is Susie send me a
picture I haven't seen a picture of
Susie
this is German Shepherd oh really I mean
you could say any kind and I would yeah
oh really
oh
let's see see German Shepherd oh that's
right that is a very formidable looking
German Shepherd that you have well done
Adelia
I gotta follow you on the gram I only
have you on X the everything I have such
I don't know
[Laughter]
Susie's two German Shepherds I hope that
both of you are well and we'll catch you
next time